i i had driven all the way out to this
prison outside of town you know for a
conjugal visit and i get all the way out
there after that huge long drive and
it turns out you have to know somebody
[Laughter]
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god
with me george lopez
sport sporting paul you know george is
oh i'm sure he's around here somewhere
what's his name george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
if you're enjoying omg high please
support our sponsors first up we have
sunday lawn care sunday lawn care helps
you grow a beautiful lawn without the
guesswork or the nasty chemicals get 20
off your full season custom plan then go
to
getsunday.com
omghi
20 that's gitsunday.com
omghi 20.
uh grant
can you tell us yeah uh i assume who's
joining us on the podcast today we've
got uh sean pelosi and vicki barbalak
comedians actresses and hosts of the
upcoming trailer park diaries podcast
we're thrilled to be here yeah now first
of all let's talk about your
your entrance into comedy
yeah okay how long have you known each
other
20 some years 23 years 24 years
sounds good yeah yeah and you met uh
back in the belly room oh really yeah we
met in the belly room the comedy store
we did a show and she said we should
have dinner she was going to pay for our
dinner for going to the belly room but
but she didn't a media friend a mutual
friend she didn't pay yeah she didn't
show up so we were there and we had to
buy our own dinner and it was tough but
anyway she was a
terrible person anyway so it was kind of
a relief she wasn't there so um so we
met that night and i asked her she would
split dinner with me and she jumped
across the table and hit me said no no i
would never share with and she only ate
half her food it made me so mad did you
guys remember we went to go eat mouse
yeah mel's melody oh belle's uh down
there on sunset where else are you gonna
go out for the comedy we were served by
the former comedy store managers yeah
yeah that was before we discovered
pequito moss though
which is delicious
is good there's bean cheese right down
the street yeah pizza's tacos yes been
there done that right there like you
were like kind of beyond uh day to day
at the store i was already
listen i've been around a long time one
time when i was working during the day
over there in in uh
and we went to go see a movie being a
guy at work a guy was a pain in the ass
and we went to go eat at some italian
place and he goes i don't have my wallet
and i said
i said i don't have my wallet i did but
i told him i didn't
so uh
i left to go get money and i never went
back
i don't know
he's like the boss's son you know so
they're like trying to make me hang out
with the boss's son and i said he goes i
don't have my wallet
and then i that that split second when
you go
yeah you know i don't think i have mine
either i'm clear and then the waiter was
you know kind of like back in the desert
kind of like none
nobody's leaving and then i said let me
go i'll leave you here and then i'll go
get some money the old climb out of the
window in the bathroom trick like in
fascinating the ridgeman
i used to do that in synagogue all the
time hebrew school we'd be like we'll be
right back and then we climbed out of
the window and went to school do you
think that it's uh more work to be
jewish than it is to be catholic yeah
look at me of course i think it is i'm
exhausted
[Laughter]
because hebrew school and and that
that's
like it's for life i think right i think
you have to stop learning 13 a bar
mitzvah that that's that's pressure
what's the preparation before bat
mitzvah well you you meet with the rebbe
because i like to say rebbe you meet
with the the the rabbi is that your
rabbi that you've had since you were
really young not anymore because i
i grew up jewish in oklahoma so that is
yeah take a moment for that gil um but
it was like a whole thing so but i grew
up actually conservative jewish my
parents were from brooklyn
so we were you know there wasn't many of
us did your dad company move to oklahoma
my father went to medical school at
oklahoma university and then he
established his neurosurgery practice
there wow he's a nervous case anyone
ever needs a brain surgeon
he's a little shaky now you don't know
you don't want that in your brain but
you know that the yeah i guess when when
you get a little bit shaky yeah there
goes your eyesight yeah
it's like when willie mays got old and
tripped running for uh uh baseball
they're like i think it's time to yeah
you tripped and everybody in the stadium
was like i think it's time to put willie
out yeah
uh so okay so so you meet with the
rabbit you go to you go to hebrew school
for like
uh maybe like six seven years you go for
a long time but then when you have to
like practice and learn your half tour
and all that that's like your whole
summer it's a dance the huff tour yes
that's a
it's a lot and and uh
i mean listen we had to go to catechism
and then we could miss two months and go
back
i'm glad i was catholic yeah i wouldn't
have put up with all the i couldn't no i
could have done it but there's there's a
reward to that years though
there's the reward of the party yeah you
make a lot of money like like now today
i attended my friends kids bar mitzvah
she she made like she got a 401k like
she she made a lot of money more money
than i probably made in my lifetime and
i'm like what's going on like that was
the good thing you've got gifts and it's
a college fund it's like uh um
there's not strangers that you're
invited it's all family and friends it's
a big deal well you know maybe a couple
of strangers yeah you know depending how
rich they look
yeah remember
you have confirmation when you get like
a pinata nothing i mean we didn't get
anything like that as catholics you know
did you do confirmation in mexico you
could tell how you know pinata was like
very elegant but in mexico they have a
thing called the bolo
where they take change
and the guy will stand in the middle of
the room before the backyard and throw
the money in the air
and then all the kids run after it and
they
bump hit each other in the head and
knock each other out and they're
fighting over coins that's interesting
and the bolo yeah you get you learn to
get the hell out of the way but my
daughter got trampled uh
because my wife had you know the kids
were hitting the pinata in the backyard
and a wooden bust their kids are like
four years old so she really kind of
tore it and it kind of went like carry
you know like all the candy all over
and she's standing there like this and
those kids attacked her yeah yeah she
went down and face in the you know
they're just kind of
grabbing all the candy around her yeah
and you're like that's not you know
they're so dangerous we always had them
too and i always thought it was just
because i was white and i didn't know
how to operate them but i think they're
dangerous for everybody i mean there's
never a time when somebody's not going
to get hurt you know
i've seen enough sopranos where you just
give somebody an envelope you know
[Laughter]
god bless you know they give you an
envelope
you know uh and then uh what did they
say that one time in the sopranos like
the guys got busted and the guys went
back there and go they were looking in
the bag and they were grabbing their
envelopes back like like
yeah they took the guy away we're taking
our money back yeah but but seven years
is a and do you do you remember the is
it like a driver's license like if you
if you pass hebrew school that you never
have to worry about going back see you
know what it it was like
very fortunate i got to study i didn't
have obamacare alone i had a bene bar
mitzvah which is two so my sister and i
were pretty close in age not like irish
twins closed but we were close enough
that you know all our relatives lived in
new york so if they had to go back and
forth to oklahoma which nobody wants to
do from new york
so we we study together so we had our
bar mitzvah together so we both took
turns torturing the rabbi which is
basically what you do through those
sessions and it's just like you don't
want to commit to it but you know that
you have to because there's the pressure
from the family and you got to get it
right and when you have to sing hebrew
i'm not a good singer i mean i although
i look like one i do i i sing terribly i
sing terribly and so and and that's what
you have a deep voice like you have a
voice that could be a good singer well
my balls just dropped george but yeah
other than that but i bet my balls drop
a lot more i'm older than you
they're down there i mean you're like
what the [ __ ] man
if you let them hang they're gonna drop
but if you you know if you wear
underwear there's some support you know
yeah yeah we have the bra concept yeah
yeah yeah it's an awful thing too ours
is on top yours is on bottom you know
when you get to the age where you look
better clothes
yeah when you just like like when you
have sex it's like when you go have
surgery they just isolate that one area
maybe they just put a sheet over it with
a hole in there your penis is out there
amish sex that's all i ever do anyway
wait are we supposed to have sex with
without our clothes off isn't that a
thing
so so uh um and and who entertained who
what enter what entertainment did you
have at your at my party yeah well we
had our party in the the backyard we
lived on a lake and uh we just had this
really lovely big backyard so it was
just a band
and um you know we didn't have like uh p
diddy perform or anything like that
nobody just like i know they do
i know they do they do some big-time
[ __ ] now yeah yeah i mean they go
you know my daughter went to uh campbell
hall and around that age
she came back with a picture of of her
and an elephant
and i'm like what the [ __ ] get to the
[ __ ] elephant
uh at the at the bar mitzvah the girl
had another like an elephant like a
circus as you do and then they had a
a book leaflet and i said what's this
book oh they made this book at the party
and you open it up and it's pictures of
all her friends and the girl and you're
like they [ __ ] made books yeah i had
a guy back there making books it's crazy
yeah there's a lot going on today but
you know at least she didn't bring
[ __ ] the elephant home so that would
have been a problem and now it is but it
was never about like how much money you
had it was a ceremony yeah but they've
turned it into how much money you have
right exactly well it's a it's a
production it's bigger than a wedding
it's bigger than a wedding you have to
go on a diet if you're a mom for months
yes
all my jewish girlfriends they do diet
before the kids bar mitzvahs for like a
year big deal also you have to look yeah
yeah i'm going to like two next month
and now it's like every other friend's
kid is getting borrowed by mitzvot so
you know what's the proper amount like a
thousand oh to give yeah well for you
george it is for me a couple hundred no
a couple of 100 couple hundred
oh wow and how many people go to one
typically well um i mean i've been to
ones that were like 500 and i've been to
ones that were like a hundred it just
depends especially in like the time of
covet or whatnot people sometimes they
you know what i was in 2009 when i was
flying around i was going to do my hbo
special i was going between houston and
san antonio and we were at the houston
four seasons and i you know we've been
drinking we're on a private plane we get
back to the hotel and i tell the bellman
what's the biggest tip that you ever got
and he goes somebody gave me 500 bucks i
said [ __ ]
for what for bringing the bags up
somebody gave me 500 bucks so i said
okay put your hands out and i gave him
600 bucks and then i said who gave you
500 bucks and he goes you did last
saturday
i said he goes you didn't say who you
said what oh that's so i [ __ ] had no
idea
i gave him 500 bucks
god you know what we look like when i
waited tables we looked for people like
you george to come in and typist and i
used to work with neiman marcus and
beverly hills in their restaurant
downstairs the mariposa i bring vicki in
all the time would you who would you see
in there oh
everything okay ready we would have
nancy reagan
then we'd have jodie foster at the bar
then we'd have like the prince of dubai
would come in so they cleared the store
uh stevie nicks i waited on uh kathy
bates i waited on roseanne there
i remember her going um i didn't tell
her i was a comic and she's like what
should i order and i was like the
lobster cup she's like why and i'm like
because it's the most expensive
like people came in all the time but it
was kind of like saturday night live in
there because it was just a cast of
characters and people that would come in
and these people just everyone had so
much money they would just run the [ __ ]
out of you and it's lunch it's [ __ ]
lunch
why do i have to be like darling could
you do me a favor could you go upstairs
to the third floor and get me low-fat
yogurt no i can't i'm i'm running around
there were a lot of tables and everybody
was very high maintenance
and uh but but you saw a lot of
comedians in the uh um
yeah so they would go in there and have
lunch right like it was like a cafeteria
yeah i had sugar ray leonard i mean name
it everybody and anybody the best one
was george michael he came in one day
and the restaurant was empty because it
was like four o'clock before it closed
and i was the only one on and i didn't
know there was all these like japanese
girls lining up outside the restaurant
which was just like what's going on here
and then you heard screaming and then he
came in
and then he sat down and he was very
polite and nice and it was it was like
right
after the whole uh caught in the park
thing so uh but he was he that was
probably the biggest the biggest
celebrity i ever you know you think with
as much you know gay activity as we have
in west hollywood which is right down
the street from beverly hills yeah i'm
very involved in that whole gay activity
it's less than a mile from touching toes
in the park
that you know you just go to uh one of
those buyers out there high tops or you
know fiesta cantina not that i know but
uh
but you know i think it's easy to get
blown especially during the day yeah
i've never been invited out there well
gil would you like to go
hold
but um
i saw george michael in the mid 80s walk
with i would presume it was his manager
across the street and he had like
designer jeans he was very thin he had a
black v-neck
uh sweater on
he had the caesar haircut and he had
those like big versace glasses and like
dingle boots like beetle boots and that
[ __ ] looked sexy i would've
how to keep going but i mean
he looked like a greek god
he he was that he was in his he was in
his element he's walking like this and
not an ounce of fat on him and you're
just like whoa
so how did you uh how did you how did
you guys find your way to comedy
go ahead vicky so i was like 40 when i
started and i literally loved that yeah
i started i i took sandy shore polly's
sister's class comedy class in in la
jolla and i just you know just did it
for lark and then i started loving it
and mitzi saw me
about a year after that and in la jolla
one night and she made me regular for
hollywood i don't even know what a paid
regular was i had no idea oh [ __ ] no
idea i didn't know but you had been
already a fan of comedy before i was
just so like so sheltered i didn't i
literally didn't know i i never i went
to the comedy store in hollywood one
time never saw any live shows just
listen to records didn't date a lot
anyway so i didn't know much hey listen
man
no listen nobody who's the life of the
party is going to become a [ __ ]
comedian exactly you have to be in there
where they're like dude get some sun man
you walk out and you're flaky all kind
of [ __ ] on you because
you're the doing comedy is the last
[ __ ] resort yeah of show business i
mean you know you could be a [ __ ]
fire breather but you know
you could do that with nobody around to
be a comedian you have to be like
i mean listen john bobby got his dick
cut off and it sewed it back on and
didn't attach the right way and he said
i think i'm going to become a comedian
exactly he did porn then he didn't stand
up
you're like going to compete i'm like
poor but there's a bunch of [ __ ] cato
kalin did uh
uh stand up and uh rock rocky laporte
yeah john mayer i heard johnny mayer
does stick like does he not get enough
[ __ ] like dude like bring it down we
got you you're a rock star just stay in
that lane but you know when you get a
lot of [ __ ] you you don't appreciate it
because you're kind of on the bottom of
the barrel you're like this is only
because i'm funny it's not
any other but it's all right that's the
way i feel i think it's so i think it
works different for women because
as a comedian that
when if a woman is standing on stage
she's funny you can just see some of the
men's faces in the audience and i i feel
like it was harder to pull dick
and so to the point where i had to trick
them into marriage you know what i think
that's did you meet your husband in a
club
uh yes and no it was only because a gay
friend brought his co-workers to the
club
to see me so i knew he who my friend was
bringing and he had told me that one of
them was brazilian so i'm not dumb
wasn't born yesterday like my men brown
thank you
and uh i knew that he was coming so i
kind of set my eyes on him but didn't
think much and so the first time he did
see me was in the club wow
yeah and how did you do
um i did okay i picked on him and i
picked on uh the argentinians
did you remember what you said to him
uh well i yeah i gave him a heart
because i had people from new zealand in
the front row two guys and i was talking
about how they're probably
uncircumcised and and then i kind of
went into a bit there and then i said oh
rafael you're from brazil
you know you've you've got a sneaky
snake and he goes come on and then that
was what i had said to him so then um i
pit him against the there was a woman
from argentina and so i just i think it
was just like
foreign person night and i just was kind
of improvising with the crowd is there a
personality trait of an uncircumcised
person versus a circumcised guy can you
tell usually south american
we'll start there
yeah because it's like what do they call
like an anteater that's what your name
is yeah we call it a sneaky snake sneaky
snake the german helmet versus the
anteater yeah you know it's the whole
thing okay it wrote like names of robots
the helmets versus the sleeping bag but
vicky vicky tell them how you met your
your third husband oh yeah lou is my
favorite so far he's a piano player in
la jolla at the comedy scene the comedy
star yeah he's been there you've been
married three times yeah yeah i'm on a
roll wow no no no no so so so uh um what
was who was the first comedian that you
saw that made that made an impact on you
guys
for me personally
i don't know if it'd be stand-up wise it
was bette midler yeah amazing that just
that just the way she is an entertainer
in all shapes and like
just what she does i mean one moment she
can have you crying when she's singing
in the next minute you know somebody
i've seen her concert and someone's like
we love you ben she's like i know honey
but you're gay you know she just is like
so fast
and versatile and you know when you saw
the rose which was kind of like janice
joplin's right aren't you waiting for
them to try and remake that actually
[ __ ] with that oh but they will at some
point yeah yeah did you ever see the
rose yes it's very good huh
because uh
she just was like a force of nature man
she could sing to the bugle boy
and she was funny and she was pretty
amazing she could rock
and she
you know still is
she's dynamic amazing everything i met
her twice and i scared the [ __ ] out of
her but uh that when i met her oh my god
did anybody like that ever see you do
stand-up ever see you guys do stuff i i
phyllis stiller was like for me just
growing up and i loved her so much and i
did a show called funniest mom in
america and she was judging that night
and and when i found out she was there i
just lost it i was like no i'm going to
really meet phyllis dylan that [ __ ]
laugh was amazing yeah she was scared
that's so awesome that night she got to
see me perform and she's like you know i
love you and i was like well she laughed
loud
and didn't give a [ __ ] if it was popping
ha ha
like didn't care who was in the room
like she she didn't chuckle laughs she
laughed yeah she laughed men had big big
balls back then
not that they don't now but they they
don't have as big a balls as they used
to in general i think we have to you
know they're tapping it down but back
then i mean she was like in the room
with just big big giant ego giant men
comics and she always like held her own
it was so she was amazing she
when you hear somebody laugh like that i
i wrote uh for fashion police for a
little bit for joan rivers and i
remember being just so frightened the
first day and you're sitting around a
table full of writers and everyone is
better than the next and it's like oh
here you go and you got to deliver your
ten jokes about one picture of rihanna
and it's the same chris brown [ __ ] joke
you know you're like how do i find
something different to say
and she had this system
where
if if if she liked your joke she kind of
like she'd pat the back of the chair and
her head writer would write it down and
that would be a joke she'd use for the
show the next day and so if you heard
her laugh and you saw her do the pat
that that or she used your joke that
meant everything like that was a moment
where i was like i can't believe i'm
sitting in a room
with joan rivers amazing yeah you know
when joan rivers was on my talk show i
said
you know i had the biggest crush on you
when i was growing up she was what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
[Laughter]
i looked i said remember that you're not
[ __ ] wrong
remember that unicorn commercial you had
for tires she goes yeah i go that would
do it for me what
you know we're all tired
and uh we had a contest we had a square
jar
and her and i went back and forth and
had money
and we would just put it into this jar
and i'd say my grandmother was a [ __ ]
and she goes my mom was a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
amazing yeah
god i mean you know i i think that you
know people like that that
like you
can you can feel
their comedy like in them you know when
you see them they're already like i mean
i saw richard pryor in front of the
comedy store
and he just looked different that almost
looked like they were elevated beyond
you know i saw
letterman in the early 80s and you know
i've seen that i've seen everybody talk
to everybody but
it uh
i don't know you know i think social
media kind of deluded the significance
of the stand-up comedian
you know like bill burr and those guys
like you know they're always at the
comedy store which is amazing you know
but there's a lot of people that
are youtube influencers and you know
they kind of pee in the pool you know
yeah
it's hard to get your head around them
because you know you don't see them in
the clubs but yet you know they sell out
six shows uh all the time every and
you're like well you know what i know
you know i mean i can't wear cameras and
film and but if they think if they are
out of their element they can't survive
yeah it's funny though they do have
these loyal fans that just show up and
yeah it is but you wonder how long it's
going to last how long is sustainable
for until they get another but who knows
it's just an interesting thing that's
going on yeah and you guys husbands get
along with each other oh yeah yeah i
mean they're so different and so it's
like extreme
extreme so brazilian and and and a jew
she married the jewish guy wow yeah
totally high piano player he can't hear
a thing that's why the only reason he's
still with me
how abound in death tell them the book
that you're writing what the [ __ ] you're
writing a book it's true it's called
your husband hates the sound of your
voice
i just finished with my editor a few
minutes ago yeah yeah yeah that's
awesome that's awesome
it's hard to imagine but spring is
almost here we're so close to feeling
that soft grass under our feet but first
we need to get our lawn back thankfully
sunday gets your lawn growing and helps
to keep it healthy all season long
sunday can help you grow a beautiful
lawn without the guesswork or the nasty
chemicals their custom plans include
fertilizer and everything you need to
easily care for your lawn and with
ingredients like seaweed iron and
molasses you can feel good with kids and
pets being around it too all you have to
do is visit sunday.com put in your
address and the lawn analysis tool does
the rest they then use soil and climate
data to create a personal nutrient plan
delivered to your door right when you
need it and best of all
this stuff just really works my favorite
part is the easy delivery like i'm a
delivery man this is the 21st century i
love anything that can come straight to
my door uh so you know that's one of my
favorite parts here so sunday is
offering our listeners 20 off
full season plans start at just 129 and
you can get 20 off at checkout when you
visit getsunday.com
omghi 20. that's 20 off your custom plan
at getsunday.com
omghi 20.
when when you when you started to do
stand-up did you feel like your life was
was
going in a good direction like to be
around comedy and to be writing it like
right immediately like i had been
selling carpet for 20 years of my
parents business and i was not the
employee of the month ever they hated me
and i was miserable the whole time it
was awful and uh and so i just thought i
was gonna have a miserable life i love
being a mom but other than that i
married the wrong man i was just
miserable and i thought that's how i i
picked a miserable life and that's it i
never thought it would change i didn't
know it would change i thought it was
done and then i just took this little
class and i just started going to open
bikes and i i told my parents in a few
years just
sell the store i don't want it and i
just jumped into a trailer i bought a
trailer with my daughters and we moved
into a trailer and we just were poor for
like
we're happy i'm so glad i did you bought
the trailer you went and looked at it
you walked inside a thousand bucks from
a transgender lady with a whole closet
full of guns and gowns and uh and
that's great and what was she doing she
was selling it she was selling it she
was moving on like to tennessee or
something wow and so my she liked my
daughter emily and she gave us like 5
000 bucks off about it for 11 000.
and we just started living the trailer
life and
it was just been great so you lived the
trailer life but did you live the
training life
no uh i i did not live very quickly
a jew and a trailer they'd come and get
you like come on
we're
no i didn't i was i was fortunate uh i i
i grew up pretty well
and went to usc
and uh thank you fight on thank you
and then uh i i went to i always acted
as a little kid so i always liked uh
comedy in that sense because i thought
my path would be more of an snl i always
did characters and impersonations
so i was always in school plays and
drama contests and just always you know
i had a very funny family and so when i
went on to usc and then i majored in the
school of theater which was very
productive really helpful towards my
career
and then when uh i was studying at usc i
took with the groundlings and i was in
class with like will ferrell and i saw
him as like a bank teller and then i
just watched like how people's careers
changed after working with all these
groups
he was a bank teller at the time also
graduate of usc and so i kind of just
fell into stand-up that was like i'll
take a stand-up class when i graduated
college and i did it like once for that
first year and i still stuck with sketch
comedy and then something about me was
just like you know we're not really
bringing in a bunch of audiences here at
acme comedy theater and i started doing
stand-up here and there and that's like
when i would do shows in the belly room
and i saw
when i saw vicki on stage because she's
just like this
beast of one-liners and she was such a
killer writer and she was such a
character already she she didn't need a
point of view it was all there she lived
in a trailer she was a mother like a
single mother of two at the time and she
was just dynamic and i thought god you
know she really watching her make
someone like myself step up their game
right and
and yeah we came from such different
backgrounds but yet and i was like so
blown away by her because there weren't
that many women back then working there
really weren't and uh and so it was just
so fun to to find her you all right yeah
okay little gasps
[Laughter]
well you're sitting in a chair sideways
that's probably why what's in the red
can beer
what kind of beer
hibiscus beer please can i have that
direct chair for this george are you do
you do do you design these flavors
yourself and you just that might be sour
for you but this is like an orange sour
i like the sour too oh yeah oh was that
beyonce on the front no it's some
chicano
[Laughter]
we'll say that i have to pay her i
always keep for the other side of the
camera
oh my gosh this is great but i saw it's
really good who did i see when i when i
was still in high school
i also have another hotel store the
calories are in there uh we you know we
don't we don't count we don't cook it's
delicious you know uh less than if it
was a 32 ounce thank you the uh
[Laughter]
so so i was in corpus christi the omni
and then i come down we're still flying
the same week and then there's a guy
that's having his 40th anniversary
uh did i say that's our story already i
don't think so all right yeah don't you
[ __ ] it's like uh
you're like a chaplain thing like i'm
talking
he's trying to get it to the chest
like me and the rabbi yeah you all right
you all right and then the uh uh there
was a guy that was kind of you know like
this and it said congratulations on 40
years you know retirement and someone
had drawn a dick with it in his mouth
and balls and i was like oh man this is
awful i love that though this [ __ ]
guy is going to come over here his
family is going to see the picture
somebody drew a dick and balls and the
the bellman goes you you drew that last
night when you got to them
no well done and i said i think he said
you didn't give him my sharpie back i'm
like oh all right
[ __ ] it up in my room but i guess i when
i was blacked out i probably was
abandoned i loved it probably their
prized possession in their life the
woman i was just having a good time like
you don't have a thousand dicks if uh
and and you know i pissed off a lot of
people but it's like
if i wanted to conform i would have
stayed working during the day
yeah i think at some point
when you do something that's different
than everybody else you have to
be about that you know race car drivers
when they drive they could die
and comedians
you got to go up
and eventually whether you're trying to
duck it or not like i always say instead
of my wife you know
eventually you have to put them up right
you can get a good crowd you can catch
yourself a couple times and then when
you do you don't do good when there's
not a lot of people but you got to do
good whether there's five people or 500
people yep and at some point you got to
put them up yeah that's true i felt like
mitzi shore
because she was taking on a bunch of
female comics at the time vicky and i
got past because she wanted to bring
women back into the belly room to kind
of
ease the energy because i guess back in
the day that's when it was really it was
high yeah and so
when she passed vicky and i it was just
it was
that's a pretty big deal that's a pretty
big deal to get past mitzi shore
it was great and we were lucky you know
because you know she didn't get to work
with that many more people right so
we're just like you know the tail end
and then you know when you realize what
you got when you shed me over your house
for the first time and
i was like so shaky and she goes go up
and take a nap and she said the right
thing she was the first door in the
right and the stairway went two
different ways so i just laid on the
tile i didn't want to disturb a bed
and i was just like oh it's just it was
so much fun being with her and and and
the way she works with you what she does
secretly you know to make you get better
it was um you know what that's pretty
good because nobody's ever talked about
that like everybody thought you know she
was pretty hard on comedians and and
rightly like you wouldn't think she was
paying attention and she sat there in
the back with like a little light you
could see the glasses yeah hanging at
the tip of her nose and she was paying
attention oh yeah you know she could
look down and she could look up and she
could and was always
paying attention you know but the story
behind that is if you were trying to
become a regular at the comedy store
when you were showcasing in front of
mitzi shore in la every comic tried to
[ __ ] block you while you were showcasing
she'd sit in the back of the room and
comics would purposely come up to talk
to her
and so they would distract her but she
was smarter than that
but i saw it so many times and it was
like vicious
yeah
you know i uh spoke at richard pryor's
funeral you know and um
david banks who was
do you guys ever meet david
david banks was as funny as richard
pryor wow i mean he was he was uh
really funny like hood funny like that
and he was an usher at richard's funeral
and he and i are standing in the middle
of the little white chapel at forest
lawn and we see somebody really tiny
just all this hair and it's missing
she's walking and she's got the you know
program in her hand
and when she passes us
david banks catches her on the arm and
he goes don't leave you'll be back
wednesday oh no
oh my god oh my god i [ __ ] told her
she'll be back well oh my god
oh my god i ran outside he goes where
the [ __ ] did you go i said man i ran
outside dude i was like the timing of it
because he let her he saw her here and
he let her get by here and then went
like that it was like just at the time
is he still around david no he passed
unfortunately i wonder if we could find
him anywhere online i think you could
yeah yeah he did he did all of the
richard pryor uh type shows and stuff
like that oh neat you know there was a
lady golfer that i played golf with up
in la kington she lived in a in a mobile
home what what's that like i had friends
growing up in san fernando that lived
yeah in mobile homes and when you're
like in fifth grade you think it's cool
to ride your bike through a um yeah a
trailer park i still i still love the
way the sunlight hits the aluminum at
sunset i think it's so romantic but you
know what vicky vicky does live in a
glass i mean a very you live in a
glamorous
you're in the 1970s you don't live in
light it's not very good
i think it is oh yeah if i can stay in
it
in my own yard i got a corner lot no i
don't want to brag top of the hill ever
since agt things were really changed
yeah yeah still the same person inside
but [ __ ] i got the [ __ ] and trailer
it's beautiful that's right you
america's got talent yes yes vicki was
the final one
it was killing me trailer nasty y'all
think yes that's so nice thank you
remember you yeah and you know what
that's right that's not a [ __ ] easy
thing to do it was it was a it was a um
you know i've been doing it i'd solidly
for 20 years before that and you know
it's like because i was old and fat when
i started and but
it was back the time when people went
looking at different people so i could
never get anyone in la besides missy to
look at me so but i just kept loving it
and doing it that agt thing the way that
takes america around the industry it was
the best thing that ever happened so and
i enjoyed the whole process the two two
minute thing it was like a zen thing at
first i'm like this isn't comedy this is
[ __ ] and then the more i got into
those two how many jokes can you do in
two minutes five it depends you could do
one long two minute joke or two or three
you know just i put little index cards
together and the bartender at la jolla
comedy store just say and i would lay
the bar and get the cards out yeah but
anyway yeah it was i'm six i'm three a
minute yeah well you know oh i was three
minutes is that funny how you can know
that yeah
you can know that yeah i don't have that
answer and did you and you always have i
think one of the toughest things to do
is to find
like a solid opening line totally it has
to be the opening in the end right you
put whatever you want in the middle you
open that was it trophy y i mean vicki
just i mean it to watch vicky over the
years work so hard and and get
you know the
the props that she deserved i mean she
got a standing ovation her first time
out and i would have cracked and totally
laid down and died but to watch what was
your first set what was your first set
to get a standing ovation i mean that's
oh god you walked out there they were
probably laughing already i think it was
uh i think it was uh it was uh it was
trophy i mean like nobody looking at me
like you never saw a trophy wife in
hollywood
but then it was uh it was very very bad
rain in san diego uh you know it never
rains and people can't drive and uh i
had driven all the way out to this
prison outside of town you know for a
conjugal visit and i get all the way out
there after that huge long drive and
it turns out you had to know somebody
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's awesome yeah
incredible and then when you go out
there so you have to judge between
the applause
and when to start
yeah right
because you go out there and they see
you and they start laughing like oh [ __ ]
they're tripping out on you but you
can't last too long when you're in like
um you know i've not been you know i've
very rarely been in big theaters more
than like 1500 people but like i would
imagine at your level because like where
you two or how big your spaces are that
must become like a real nightly decision
because there's so many people out there
to see you and you want to acknowledge
that they spit that money and they're
here to see you but then you also want
to go i don't want to be an [ __ ] with
you know i got to do this it was a it's
a process because you know it
was i was when i got the first show like
20 years ago i was still in clubs
and then i went to theaters and then
in like three years i was like in arenas
yeah
i remember i fired this guy that was a
dj because we were in austin at the at
ut where the university of texas plays
basketball and he gets up there he comes
up behind me goes jesus christ this is
going to be full with people you're not
nervous i said man you're fired dude
so in the in the in the trailer park
life
uh i mean there's trash i mean you do
meet
you're such good characters but i mean
they're not bad people no there's some
there's some wackos and there's some
beautiful people like the other day i'm
not kidding this woman she has a good
friend of mine she she's like 85 her
name is carol and she's been diagnosed
with parkinson's last couple years and
literally i'm at the pool because we
hang out at our pool all the time it's
heated i don't want to brag but anyway
so she was sitting by the pool and she
puts her hand on my hand and she said
you know vicki you know i just want you
know as you get older you know ron and i
we still have sex
and i still have multiple orgasms and
i'm like maybe it's the parkinson's
they're just sitting on the pool telling
me that something that's amazing i just
love the things you hear at the pool and
the people it's just fantastic i mean we
have a golf cart parade every year it's
just yeah it's it couldn't be better but
you know that um
you know comedy is really about meeting
characters yeah about being around or
being around characters yeah so you know
me and a friend of mine from high school
he goes hey i got us a job
as like landscapers on saturday
over there in van nuys and
he gets there and we get there the guy
has the trays of
of of little plants that you know we
have the thing he and i
and then you know out there this [ __ ]
guy's got a huge yard he's got like a
thousand of these little fussy like
[ __ ] cupcakes in a football field
and i'm like son of a [ __ ] and toward
the end of the day you end up getting a
little bit sloppy man and the guy would
yell at me from the porch you're
stepping on my varieties
i had no i guess that's what they called
me with different different flowers and
every time i took a step i stepped in
more of his varieties
but then sometimes uh when i get uh uh
together with that guy and we've known
each other for like 40 years i'll say
you're stepping out by variety
we saw i sold area code books
door-to-door in by the va hospital in
van nuys oh my god [ __ ] what kind of
book is it well let's say you have some
friends in montana i don't have friends
in montana well let's say you do it and
you needed to know the area imagine
selling a [ __ ]
book of area codes and you would leave
that's hilarious you would leave a paper
in the morning and then
circle back
and the fact even if somebody opened the
door you'd be like just thank you for
opening the door we don't watch your
[ __ ] book but at least we'll open the
door for you you're just like what that
that [ __ ] is a an
area code book
yeah and you think comedy's hard oh my
god should i sell an area because he's
in my trunk
[ __ ] oh no we were finally done i put
all all the books through there that
slash books and he goes my guy arnold
goes where's where are the keys
i thought you had the keys we locked him
in the
[ __ ] trunk we had to walk get the
[ __ ] bus and walk off oh god
stepping our varieties all the way back
but i mean you know
it's it's kind of like uh
those people that you meet that
i had a guy with cerebral palsy that i
was helping us from indiana and i said
you know dan fly off
fly out here and you can stay with me
and i'll get you a couple of gigs and he
says to i mean he had a hard time
walking
and he said if i fall
don't pick me up
because i have to learn to to pick
myself up
this [ __ ] fell every 10 minutes
so
i would just be talking to my
grandmother you're here
look around the corner and you could see
his cane in the air like this
he's on his back and the cane is like
this
like
in the air but he's on his back
like a turtle you would at least [ __ ]
roll him over so i go dan you need some
help no i'm fine [ __ ] cane in the air
and then 20 minutes late and you're just
like
and then you didn't want to pick a map
and you're like [ __ ] he falls every
10 minutes
we got [ __ ] to do oh that's hilarious
but i mean the the characters that you
that you meet
you know um
and the and the podcast you guys haven't
you haven't premiered yet right no
no it's gonna be soon though within
moments yeah yeah march 22nd it you know
i think kind of
just features really because vicky and i
we're an unlikely
pair of besties yeah and we're kind of
like the you know a little more modern
day absolutely you you oh
first of all getting her into a thrift
store is not easy but it was in santa
barbara i mean it's it's the that's why
the homeless looks so good there they're
all wearing the wrench it hurts george
it hurts so i found this really
expensive like i'd rather get a
mammogram than go into her and i said
you could just wipe it off and and she
went nuts that's [ __ ] hilarious
you don't like knew when you just shaved
it off it was fine it's almost like if
you if you if you took the black part of
the banana away that's right you still
have a good banana but my grandmother
would go like this [ __ ] bananas
passing we're leaving after paid the
lipstick we're leaving and i i slowed
down by the bathing suits and she just
grabbed me
so
yeah but it's always like that's
hilarious yeah yeah
those
yeah those baby suits that had like the
crusher had rubber yeah like your
[ __ ] ball and you wear them like for
a whole summer and then you'll find the
rubber at the end yeah
all balled up
i hate that
yeah the [ __ ] that we yeah you know
the the highest form of sanitation when
we were growing up was that when you
were in bowling they [ __ ] sprayed
lysol in the shoe oh yeah that was it
that's it even if you said what size are
you uh i'm an 11. he's at 11 and he's
turning him back in you'll wait to get
the [ __ ] still warm from him wearing
him and you're like yeah [ __ ] it i'll
put them on i mean that's true you know
what we've become
is [ __ ] crazy man like nobody
you know my grandmother would say if you
wear if you put your shirt on inside out
it's bad luck to [ __ ] turn it back
outside in so you when you're a kid
you [ __ ] put your shirt on backwards
and she would say don't change it
because it's bad luck you're walking and
every kid in school is pulling your
[ __ ] tag
all [ __ ] day and you're trying to
tear your own tag off you know thanks
grandma oh my god one time i uh i saw a
guy and he
had some 501s on and you know would say
waist and the length and he tried to uh
lower the the the waist by putting pan
on the head
you try to change the number of his
waist to a smaller number and [ __ ]
we're like is that [ __ ]
is that a [ __ ] pen down there you're
trying to turn it into a [ __ ] h
and then
we
figured that
[Applause]
i mean it's just like [ __ ] that kids did
that that nobody would do now i remember
i wore husky pants from sears
the top
i bought my shoes at hoop my grandma
bought some shoes for me at hughes at
the market uh-huh uh-huh i mean [ __ ]
nobody give a [ __ ] i shop for my kids
school clothes at the lost and found box
at our school
one day
would you just maybe go to a different
school like a brilliant idea so i would
start going to del mar to the better
schools and get like really nice harley
way better clothes
because there's like two days a year
where they give it all away vicki's the
queen of return too she is so good at
like beating the system like you have to
be you have to be you got to raise kids
on a comic salary you got to be clipped
yeah we i nicknamed i nicknamed vicki uh
swindler's list
because
she can just figure out to outsmart
anybody in retail
i i've never seen anything like it it's
a gift yeah it's a job how did you learn
that i had to i literally had i
literally was living on you know the
literally the money that you could leave
your house and come back my grandma my
mom could do this i wasn't around my mom
a lot right but my mom could leave and
come back holding a new tv and you're
like oh you don't have a job
i've never passed a free sign without
stopping and putting in my car i don't
care what it is i have to have it i'll
give it away but yeah and then you know
there's certain stores that have a very
generous return policy um i think i'm
the one that put mervin's out of
business
first of all merman's gave everybody a
credit card that's right and they would
take anything back that's right and when
they went out of business i probably
owed them 1100
i had their little britannia shirts and
i and you know it wasn't even much like
it was like 11 a month i can't [ __ ]
pay that yeah you know and then the
mervin's over there on on roscoe and and
laurel canyon and uh
they went out of business because they
gave everybody a credit card you could
fill it out right there you're like i'm
not going to pass hey congratulations
here's your credit card you go [ __ ]
crazy in the store yep i also like if
you pay like 23 for a salmon at whole
foods and it just it's not quite as good
as you thought you should just you know
you could bring it back you'd have to
bring much back you just had to make a
small amount back and i feel like it's
hilarious well you never did did you do
that take it back yeah salmon i've done
it what yeah yeah no way yeah because it
was so expensive like it better be you
know i'm unbelievable and i thought it
wasn't unbelievable enough so i just
bring a little bit back and they just
had you through i didn't think it was
unbelievable enough
i believed it and that was a problem
there was no argument yeah there's never
an argument it's at this point i'm i'm
doing a little bit better so i
but i really do feel like all the
schwindling i did i kind of had no no
way around it no but i mean it wasn't
swindled as much well i think it was but
but but also
there's a system to be worked though yes
there is a there's that you know and it
clearly a lot of times i was within the
system and then i have to say it other
times i was without the system right and
there's some guilt involved but you know
i just go to the priest every now and
then i think he's so charming that so
it's it it disarms people they don't
know and she's funny and she's likable
and she's good people so they don't see
they don't see that
you know when jerry seinfeld bought they
were telling me you know years ago that
he bought a tuxedo you know he was very
frugal and he spent you know over a
thousand dollars on on a tuxedo and they
fitted they fit him for it and he's like
well
you know he wears it at the event and at
the end of the night he puts his hand in
his pocket and it says like jeremy piven
table 10. like somebody had taken it
back oh yeah and he bought he thought he
was buying like this this new tuxedo but
somebody had already worn it jeremy
taking it back hilarious and they sold
it to him as new oh i hope he got the
money back himself
i bought a free people jacket which i i
looked for my friend that's fancy
clothing yeah you know yeah and i i
negotiate i wanted this jacket for so
many days and months and years finally
it went on sale i bought it i get home
it had a peso in it i'm like my jacket's
been amazing
and so i called the lady at macy's i
called her up i got my jacket's been to
mexico there's a peso in there
wearing like a boy scout shirt became
like fashionable like you could get a
cub scout shirt yeah you know i think uh
who wore one like flea war one or
somebody yeah and uh in high school i i
got a uh uh
boy scout shirt and i wore it to school
one day they're like [ __ ] you're
not at the boys i said it's fashion
they still have the large number on it
and it's like you don't know it's like
it's it's it's fashion
where are the pants at it's like i'm not
a [ __ ] boy scout it's a [ __ ]
fashion it's like you're like fin mints
anyone yeah yeah right you never get
over those high school
kid memories of wearing the wrong thing
yeah so so uh in the podcast will you
guys have uh will you have guests
eventually we will have guests yeah like
what kind of what kind of we had my fifi
my french made
already but um
yeah
for right now it's it's just uh vicky
and i and it's me living in vicki's
trailer park
and
you live in the trailer park too in our
pretend life okay for the show yeah it's
a little bit it's a little bit
improvised and then it's also a little
bit fiction but i think it's fascinating
yeah even just to to imagine that you
would be there right i actually think
she did move in sometimes my sisters
actually believe i did so apparently
they don't know me
ape [ __ ] they did they thought she got a
divorce and moved into my trailer park
i'm like oh my god yeah yeah but but
does anybody move out pretty no only
when they die yeah yeah
yeah it's one of those like you're in
you're in there
especially you don't want to give up so
if someone dies can you like like
checkers can you slide to it that's how
i got my heart trailer that's how i got
the new one on the top of the hill i
watched their trash can for four years
one day there was nothing in the trash
and i called the realtor i'm like i
think something's up [ __ ] no trash
yeah
swooped in i swooped in yeah and i'm so
glad i did you know somebody that i know
the woman's husband died and
the guy walked over there in black and
he's like i was at the service and i
just want you to know if there's
anything that i can do for you just let
me know i'm peter i was friends with
your husband and she's like
well you know this house is going to be
too much he [ __ ] bought it
he went over and pretended he was at the
service
and he bought the woman's house when she
was bereaved
[Music]
that's rough it's a little low down
that's not like returning a shirt at
kohl's at all no that's that's loaded i
mean when you do that that's you know in
the trailer park where i'm in now a lot
of the people go to the alzheimer's care
centers and then
this really is happening in my trailer
park right now two people that are
neighbors the husband and wife from the
different trailers are in alzheimer's
home they started having an affair in
the alzheimer's home and the people that
still live in the houses they're
starting at fair have an affair
and this affair also broke up another
affair that was going on and now the
ladies club in our park had to separate
the food giveaway day between the
warring factions
it's very dramatic
i love it drama in the trailer
shakespeare so so so
does the trailer park take the
characteristics of the of the town
like if like in san fernando there was
there was trailer parks over there yeah
right did you live near our trailer park
yeah we would ride our bikes through
there and uh so it does take on the
characteristics of of where it is sure
like our trailer is an ocean side and
oceanside's a little more seedy than say
the next town over carlsbad which those
trailer park people think that they're
you know doesn't stink which it does and
it's sickening it's boring i hate them
oh i don't really hate him individually
but as a park
[Laughter]
they have a golf course attached yeah
you know and our park is more secretive
they do have like a golf yeah yeah yeah
and kids grow up there and they're
well yeah i just live in a family park
in vista it's a great park great time
great time really good so they have
different parks like they have senior
parks family parks and you aren't though
they kind of reflect the area that's
around yeah her trailer has a lake and
ducks it's actually a drainage really it
looks like a little it's nice
well there's ducks
is there an address or you have to look
at the number under the space i used to
have space 11 in my last park but this
this one has 225 on my address like a
real street
do you want to tell everyone exactly
where you live i do all the time no one
ever
comes she does i've seen her do it in
her show where she's like okay
she'll give her real hotel room no one
ever comes i have to tell he delivered a
box of donuts once that is all over i'm
gonna get murdered vicky you can't give
your real like when i would go to her
hotel i'm like you really gave the real
number and she'll do that and i'm like
don't do that too many crazies
you know i was in the lobby of the hotel
at the four seasons in austin and there
was an old guy with like this mexican
girl that was beautiful right so we're
looking at her we're like what the [ __ ]
is she thinking about being with that
old dude right an old guy with a young
girl george what this is when i was much
younger so
she goes upstairs and then she comes
down and she says you know you guys want
to have a drink i'd love to have a drink
with you and we have a couple of drinks
and i said i'm in now she goes what are
you in i said i'm in 7 7 13. so i go to
7 13 she goes i'll be i'll be right up 7
13 i'm in there i'm waiting for you know
and nobody opened the door to down the
hall nothing i'm saying she's going to
be in here so i look down i look at the
door it's [ __ ] 317.
oh damn you dyslexia
oh yeah i'll invert numbers because i i
just see
numbers different when google you know
sends your code to resign in i [ __ ] it
up all the time yeah 81-7 it's like 178
and still you know and and when i found
out maybe like uh i think maybe over 20
years ago
that you know my wife said you know you
could get tested and you know you can be
corrected and i thought i don't think so
because i think you know it's kind of
part of your
mental makeup so that if you you know
get retested and then you start thinking
normal maybe the part that thinks
obscure or different than everybody else
you lose
yeah there's a there's a there's a kind
of uh
an analytical thing to do what we do and
if you start to think like everybody
else then you start medicating your
brain like that yeah my one of my
ex-husbands used to leave a psychiatrist
card on my pillow every single night
when i go to bed like a candy every god
damn night there'll be a psychiatrist
thing for me to go just like john yeah
johnny
and i was like finally i'm like okay
i'll go
and and it was it turned out to be a
really great experience but i mean i
didn't get drugs or anything she she
just uh she would laugh with me it was
what services do they have at the at the
trailer park like do they have a rec
room yeah oh yeah we got a pool room
like a billion room a few beautiful pool
upstairs we got a billiard room i don't
know i should take you there i'm sorry
i know you really played pool but um we
got a and then we got a like a a big
multi-purpose room and then we have the
park went on a fake lake and
and that's it and then we have like free
food giveaway twice a week that the
charities bring which i think is really
nice one time my friend lived on reseda
and i was working during the day
and he goes we got to come over to my
place it was a brand new apartment
building and we go down to the rec room
and had a couple pool tables at one pool
table all these guys had
like the boot that was bigger
than the heel was bigger than the other
like one leg was shorter than the other
and they had uh like those forest gum
braces on one leg and they were a little
bit turned kind of like this
and there was like five guys but they
were all like in their 20s
and they all weren't bad looking guys
it's just they were a bit disabled you
know they were kind of like
sideways
every one of their girlfriends was
[ __ ] beautiful wow
and we would be playing pool and we'd be
looking over and they'd be like kissing
these guys and we'd be looking at each
other gotta get a bit disabled i said to
that dude take this [ __ ] pool cue and
hit me right
but you're just like what the [ __ ] is
going on and it's almost like if it was
like set up like that yeah i mean never
seen anything like it those guys are
walking around with the big like i mean
like seven inches of rubber and the
other one was like a flat and you're
just like what the [ __ ] what [ __ ]
club what [ __ ] club is this these
guys go to a pool spine chicks
maybe they had big settlements or
something i don't know they're all good
they're all in the same accident
man that's pretty wild man you know gill
uh you never lived in a trader park or
anything huh no he's live in the same
house for 48 years seriously did you buy
your folks house or something no no i
bought the first house i ever bought
after
i've been married three years bought the
house and that was it oh that did you
build onto it as the years went by i
modernize it and put a bigger big room
and with a with an inspector or not
permits and everything
that's awesome lives in the house that i
grew up in well she wanted to buy it
because she just said
dad i want to invest
i don't have kids i don't have a husband
but i want i see all my friends they're
getting married and they're living in an
apartment so i just want to investigate
something and have something when the
time is right so now she's got two kids
and she bought her grandparents house
yeah that's beautiful i love that yeah
because you paid
it's paid off it's paid off right no
that was not paid off i sold it and then
divvied up the money between my so my
other sisters you know my grandfather uh
was trying to teach me you know to be
responsible and he was charging me like
50 a month rent and i was working you
know during the week and i was
a thousand dollars behind i mean thank
god he died i would have never [ __ ]
said that
he fell down the stairs
he said [ __ ] i would have never [ __ ]
paid him he just give me some just give
me a little bit every week of my this
guy's [ __ ] hounding me man for fifty
dollars so funny but i died he died
i was in the i was in the hole oh i put
it on my merman's card and yeah
he
he
a he he worked in he dig ditches and
stuff and stuff like that so in the
house in the back they they added a
bathroom
but it uh was not through an inspector
you know so uh they would be digging in
the back and then you know uh over time
you know i'm like uh hey man what
happened to my bike that was back here
he goes i didn't see a bike that was
back here i said yeah i had a bike right
here he's like i don't know because
somebody stole it you know somebody took
it and years later
they were doing something in the back
with the with the sewage had had broken
in the city came in there my grandmother
lived there and i went over there and
they were digging in my [ __ ]
grandfather threw the bike in the hole
to fill it up because they didn't have
enough dirt oh
my bike in the [ __ ] trench
almost like
as filling
so that when they put the dirt in it
and there was my
[ __ ] bike cake
that's hard caked in mud pretty cheap oh
my god like 15 years later like the son
of a [ __ ]
tough that's what i get for [ __ ]
uh
god your life turned out
okay the hole i could probably find my
birth certificate back there
well my grandpa was the size of a hobbit
so he couldn't even pick up a bike and
throw it like he was a little little man
grandpa max so
grandpa max
and what did he do
well um i don't know what grandpa max
actually did i decided to be a grandpa
he always had scotch in his hand that's
what and he told jokes and he loved he
loved the world
world wrestling federation and he would
take us to those and he actually
had a heart attack and died at one
way my cousin was with him so wow yeah
my dad died in a casino too gambling
he's not happy oh yeah he was
one leg
yeah and there's a sign in san diego
what would your verona moment be and i
go i got one
but he does happy i mean i want to die
happy i want to die in a bakery having a
threesome with a fireman and a chocolate
claire i want to be like dad
you know yeah yeah i mean i guess right
yeah
yeah i don't want to die throwing my
grandson's bike in a freaking hole
that's all right it's awful so as a
grandma and he was [ __ ] looking for
it he still didn't say oh no oh can you
hear where it was yeah he saw me looking
forward he made me [ __ ] look for it
guys we're tough
go around the neighborhood you'll find
it and you look forward to this
it's [ __ ] in the hole oh that's
terrible yeah very different now you
know it's funny too because you know if
you look back on you know growing up
like in the 70s or or things like that
like i could still see
you know the pop warner team you know
practicing and the feet in the park and
you know playing literally with my
friends and all that stuff that's still
very vivid you know and i think kids now
i'm not sure if they're what their
memories will be of their childhood and
their moms are so tense like my mom and
her friends and i grew up in fountain
valley you know until i was 12. by
huntington beach over there and my mom
and friends always brought flasks on
field trips you know that's just what
they did and now you know the tension
for the young moms so different you know
i brought one on a field show but i
never heard the end it's just um it's
like the the way it is for kids today
the parents are so tense you know i just
watch my daughters be parents and it's
just like they're the parameters are so
tight very different let me tell you
i'm not gonna say the guy's name
but in when we were in elementary school
he lived on the other street little
cul-de-sac and
his mom this is in the early 70s his mom
looked like
a mexican mary tyler moore
i used to wear the tight pants and she
would wear
a white blouse but you could see her bra
through the oh through the blouse and it
was in that time when the ladies had
like the pointy yes
i tried to [ __ ] a chrysler bumper
they used to have those the rounded oh
yes oh man the pointed the pointed like
the pointed bra yeah
i don't think it was a round long but
like madonna wore like that well yeah
but you don't like it but like yeah it
was pointy yeah but what was that what
was that look like guys never had a
pointy
cup it was always rounded on that
across the street and you know they'd
see her driving to the neighborhood that
kind of [ __ ] go down there and watch
her take the groceries out oh my god so
she was not just a milf she was a mmm
like a mexican milf like
to him
she was
[Laughter]
yeah
he went on to be an attorney we had the
helms bakery man that was trying to put
the push on her they'll make me mad
[Laughter]
when i first got married i lived in a
condo and and
on occasion in the morning
you could look down and the girl you
would see the girl walk past the
bathroom like naked
and i would be in the living room with
the lights off and my wife came up
behind me what are you doing
it's like you put a [ __ ] hole in the
in the ceiling i jumped
i'm watching like this i don't see
anybody here anybody behind me she was
what are you doing
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me when we first
moved to our trailer with my daughters
you know i wasn't used to being in a
trailer and the whole front is glass two
giant glass windows in the old style
trailers and one morning i was walking
around naked in the in the up
and my daughter emily goes mom the poor
gardeners
but you know i mean
you know
now i think if if if a friend walked
through and saw like the mom i mean he
would tell his mom and they would
[ __ ]
police yeah you know yeah you just can't
masturbate anymore and somebody goes ah
there's kids being kids
yes
you know another fire one off in the
park i try to drive one time and jack
off and almost [ __ ] side swipe some
[ __ ] truck on the 14th freeway
i'm like really i really can't wait 20
minutes to get home i gotta jack off
right now at the 14 and the five
interchange oh my god
the term jackoff came from that's funny
i guess if i had one i would but
it's a little tougher for us you know
when you've seen your dick your whole
life and you've seen it in all its glory
as a young man yeah you know when you
wake up in the morning and you have a
boner you don't even know any girls
right and there it is and you clean it
and it's just this you know it's full of
blood it's cut
it it's cut good and then when you're
old and you see it's just [ __ ]
dangling there like some old [ __ ]
wind sock that somebody forgot when they
moved like a fish right have people have
those fish flags it's just like some
it's just the religious fish flags that
we're talking about you know the the oh
it's got it's just handling
it you're like man i mean just you hate
to see
it's it is a sad you remember you
remember when you were young you know
you're like just get hard for [ __ ]
just for anything that's a good thing
about being a girl and you can't see
anything down there unless you really
contort yourself yeah but i know it's uh
it's not what it used to be yeah and to
get all this uh to get old is uh
it's not easy to get all terrible
it's awful terrible you know i'll tell
you guys it is but there's also so many
great things about it
like you could just tell people that you
won't do anything that they want you to
do anymore it's just like you just don't
yeah
that's true
but yeah well you know what my my show's
like almost 20 years so i'm 20 years
older i mean i was 50 i was 41 when the
show started
and then
uh i'm 60.
but
when people see me
they'll see you in the morning
when you're 43 right and then see me in
the afternoon when i'm 60
and they'll be like are you george lopez
and i'm like yeah what do i look like he
goes oh man
you got old i said [ __ ]
[ __ ] 60 [ __ ]
i was 43 this morning when you saw me
i'm [ __ ] 60 in real life and they're
just like man your hair's wide and the
men men are so lucky because you get
more distinguished looking you know we
just get more haggard like without a lot
of work which i'm not doing you know
i remember pancho gonzalez uh that
tennis player
was dark skinned and he had he had gray
hair and i was like man that
[ __ ] looks cool it's hot right
and i'm becoming i think that you're
coming i mean
i mean it is true and you really look
really hot and it's with us we let the
hair grow gray and it's like oh my god
just drive into a cliff yeah don't do it
i have a friend who let her hair go gray
and i'm like i'm not hanging around with
you hag i'm i'm not dying this orange
and going around with you well you don't
dye your hair do you are you kidding me
of course i do all of it everything
matches yeah yeah but i bought her a
scarf i mean i'm not if i'm going to be
with you i'm not going to
i'm not going to age 20 years you look
good though why are you keep pointing at
me when you say
because she just she takes care of
things she has work done she's your fate
you do well i mean just the basics just
the basics
look at my nose that's still the same i
mean it's
like
to get another job is
is not easy right i mean even though
they've even though they've
uh
had many many years to perfect it i know
somebody a guy that had his nose done
because
he couldn't breathe through it and it
[ __ ] him up worse imagine oh bummer
imagine you go to a your transmission is
not working in your car and the guy's
like hey man we [ __ ] your transmission
it's like [ __ ]
you dude you're you're in the
transmission business i mean you [ __ ] my
car like they they steal because i think
it's still the nose or whatever but this
guy
is
i mean he has to go and get it done
all over again oh yeah but it's kind of
a rite of passage especially at the bar
mitzvah age it's it was like do you want
to get a nose job do you want to get
that done
i you know i kept mine just in case
streisand dies tragically in a boating
accident and they need me to play her
for the the biopic movie so uh but it
it's a thing i mean i've i've seen good
ones and and i've seen bad ones can you
breathe out of it and everything still
works oh yeah it still works i mean my
husband i sometimes was like you were
snoring last night you're crazy and i'm
like what what he's like you were
snoring so once in a while
i'm sorry
people snore like my my when i was
married my wife and this is
i got up at 6 45 in the morning on a
sunday morning and you hear this
i look outside i go they [ __ ] trim in
the trees
on a sunday i swear to god it sounded
like they were trimming the trees and
and she snored so [ __ ] loud and one
time we we took our daughter up to uh uh
carpenteria for the school and everybody
uh slept outside and it was me and mai
and they go where's anne and we had a
minivan with the two doors and i hit the
[ __ ] door to open and as it opens
here
she [ __ ] slept she was the only
parent that slept in the [ __ ] minivan
everybody else was outside and just you
could [ __ ] faintly hear it all night
that's a while man you got to get in the
[ __ ] car man everybody's like and get
your ass in that van because nobody's
going to be able to sleep
it's tough when you're with i had one
husband he snored so loud the door would
open and close
people videoed it yeah but you know i
went and had my nose looked at with the
doctor and he said uh
he said when did you when did you break
your nose i had no idea i broke my nose
no idea right we had no idea you put the
balls on that poster either
that's right but he knew he knew the
minute he looked like he got under they
put like some
to numb it and he's like when did you
break your nose i mean maybe during
baseball i remember when you're playing
basketball they passed it or might
reflect on somebody hit you a football
or something but
you know i didn't know i didn't know
when or i broke my nose three times and
i'm like one of those birds that don't
see windows
and i've publicly
publicly at a wedding um at a hotel i
walk right into like rocky balboa like
two headeds
and i have [ __ ] that's dangerous it's
it hurts and they'll put those little
[ __ ] daisies and you're like what are
those four right and then you see like
the side of somebody like the oil of
somebody's face outside you wouldn't
think i got glasses by now but no it
just it's it's very painful yeah you
don't wear glasses not yet wow
not yet reading glasses sometimes when
it's really really tiny tiny writing
you know
you will never you will never
succumb to the pressure of using glasses
when you need them because somebody saw
me
and i had my mouth open
and your text is like this big and
they're like uh what are you doing i'm
[ __ ] trying to see what this is
and they and my fault is still like a
number four and they're like increase
the font i'm like [ __ ] you man i'm not
blind but i i wouldn't even increase the
fund because if you increase the fund
then
what are you
now you're increasing the fund you're
blind next thing you're going to have a
a a
a little chair in the living room that
has a place where you can take a [ __ ] in
there and they roll it back on the sides
i grew up with a friend of mine that his
grandfather lived in them and then he
had a hospital bed but it didn't fit in
the room so in the middle of the [ __ ]
living room we had the hospital bed in
the living room so hope might be
watching a movie and the grandfather
would be in the middle of the of the
living room with a [ __ ] hospital bed
he goes don't tell me what's going to
happen if i can move the thing back back
up
this full-size hospital bed with a
little urine bag on the side and you're
just like man you know
in somebody's house when somebody's like
that in the house it can't help but
smell like yeah i mean the hospitals
yeah they're always cleaning but they
you know yeah
don't let me have a hospital bed in the
middle of it you can't have a hospital
bed in someone's house yeah no
uh yeah well if that's all you can
afford sometimes you just have to get a
used hospital bed
there's a lady that i work that i i know
that like she's told me that she started
to uh
uh donate some time at like an old folks
home and she she finds very worthwhile
yeah because nobody goes to see him
you know and that she
has a couple hours a week that she does
that stuff and and
and she said like i i enjoy it like i
didn't think that i it was something
that i would do
and she just started doing it and that's
so cool yeah because they're so lonely
my husband lou plays piano before kovid
in the nursing homes on some afternoons
and he just loves it
and you know i think it's so nice i mean
i i love old i love older people but
it's it's incredible like what they're
doing today
with senior living you have to be bobo
rockefeller to get a place like if you
are you got your wits about you and
you're like you know what i can't handle
this big house you're empty nesting
you're older and you want to find a
place it's like you've got to have a
gazillion dollars just to put down then
you're paying rent on top i just went to
visit my aunt and uncle in phoenix
and they just moved into a senior living
place it was like a cruise ship on land
there are 10 fancy restaurants you can
make a reservation out there was a golf
course there's a pool they had like the
amundsen theater that like it was so
they were i'm going to be in a hospital
bed on my kid's back porch in the living
room they're not going to let me in the
living room
[Music]
[ __ ] screened in backwards
yeah it's but you know what i could
always end up in the in the uh
when i had my talk show we went over to
the to the actor's home yeah and uh
you know there's people that you know
the actors that live in it but there's
people that you
remember from movies and tv wow and
they're in there and they're in their
living in there that's so beautiful and
they you know they take care of him and
all that stuff but you see some lady
walk by you're like
i said remember the lady wedding singer
that old lady she was in there wow
oh have fun and it's like people that
you know you're like oh [ __ ] that's
so and so i think when they're pretty
young now i think because if you don't
have any any family and stuff like that
like you're going to need to you know i
think i think us you know are you i said
do you spend a lot of time alone you
guys spend time alone or do you do you
prefer to be alone or you like people
around you i love my kids yeah i always
have a lot of gay men around me at all
times yeah a lot of gays yeah i have a
small amount of gays she has a thousand
i think
but those are listen if gay people like
you those are the real fans well those
are the ones that are going to take i
don't have any children so i just kind
of keep befriending younger and younger
gay men and i'm like what you're 18 you
can take care of me when i'm older like
that's just what they're going to be my
kids yeah did you did you were you
afraid of having a child
did you think about it because i think
that um
i think that it's i mean
no i never was afraid i mean it's
as a girl do you do you grow up thinking
about
being a mom when you're when you're
growing up right with dolls and all this
stuff right yeah i mean you're that's
you're taught that very young especially
growing up in oklahoma was like when you
you know yeah when are you getting
married when you're having kids i'm 14.
like that's a whole it's a whole thing
and i love children and i just i got
married a little bit later in life and
then
you know at some point we just
at this point we're kind of just
discussing maybe adoption or fostering
and helping a child so i never rule it
out but i really do appreciate children
and love them and i like i like big fans
everybody's aunt
were you in the room when your children
were delivered
back in those days two of one of us
yeah but back in the early days
the guy with the the husband would wait
outside and smoke cigarettes he's not
gonna dark the [ __ ] come on i had one
guy who wouldn't even drive me to the
hospital he's like it's too early he
literally wouldn't drive me i had to
call my mother he's like it's too early
i can't get up so you know when i was at
another another time after the show
drinking and you know i would always
talk to my friends and i'd go hey do i
sound like i'm drunk and they're like no
i said because i got to call home you
know
so i i go i got to call home man so i
don't sound like i'm drunk they go no no
so i call and my wife would be like have
you been drinking i mean always drink
but that that sometimes when it was
really bad you had to pretend like at
least uh-huh
so i'm talking to her like i don't
remember what i said and then the next
day
i call her like at one and she goes i've
been thinking about what you said last
night i said oh yeah
and she's like yeah were you serious and
i said um yeah i'm serious you really i
cause i didn't think you wanted to and
i'm like uh
no you know listen if i say if i say it
then you know i'm serious about it and i
don't have no [ __ ] idea what you're
talking about but i mean what could it
be it had to be something that
you know so i said
uh yeah i'm serious she goes you really
want to go to tijuana and adopt the
mexican kid
i was like
[ __ ] i said what the [ __ ] let's say you
said you want to go to tijuana adopt a
little mexican kid i said [ __ ] that
i got little mexican kids here
how would i go over there and get one
but i guess i was like stop local george
i never wanted to i never wanted to
adopt it i guess that night i don't know
how she got me i was like yeah
we'll pick one out come down
you're like a [ __ ]
easy yeah yeah
i don't know man i mean
how did i remember howard stern said
like when you adopt when you adopt a kid
like you you don't know what the genes
what the genes are yeah well my family
would definitely be an improvement
yeah that's awesome
well ladies it's been uh it's been a
blast man you guys are you guys are
great thank you thank you for having us
it's really been a pleasure yeah yeah
they're letting us tell the world about
trailer park yeah you tell them where
they can find it and and what what it's
going to be about yeah exactly tell the
people your social media handles all
that sort of stuff and congratulat you
guys have over 50 episodes already and
it's been so much fun listening to you
guys thank you we're inspired yes so
yeah you can listen to us on all the
podcasts yeah it's called trailer park
diaries yeah and uh premieres march 22.
we give a cocktail recipe at the
beginning of each show that we created
for eating like to drink yeah okay
yeah give up give it by the way i love
this do you you could mix that with like
the kids yeah oh my god uh give me a
cocktail or something with vodka for the
house okay well we'll do that
oh yeah this is true this is a real gift
to you
um
you take a brita filter and the cheapest
vodka you can lay your hands on like you
know the cheapest vodka you can find pop
off pop off
and you run that through a britta filter
four to six times
i'm not kidding you it is as smooth as
glass and you pour that into an empty
gray goose bottle to share with your
food
you never know
they'll never be serious oh yeah i got a
whole bunch of fake cheetos right now
with the trailer no one will know except
if i just hold it whindler's list
but wait a minute what does the filter
do like it takes one takes all the hard
hardness out of the vodka and it runs
you know how the cheap vodkas taste all
hearty you run it through i actually
learned it years ago from a friend of
mine who's an artist and has all these
art shows in la with rich people so he
learned how to filter the vodka and so
i've been just doing it ever since it's
amazing
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] ghetto though
i mean wow well i mean but it's good i
mean it's
this is what we teach you on trailer
park diary yeah through a bretta filter
i mean come on six times you can't mess
around what's the worst vodka pop off or
kamchatka yeah i haven't had chocolate i
buy a lot of them at grocery outlet they
don't even have names did you guys hear
that they're changing the name of
stolich naya outside of russia they're
they're gonna just call it stoli from
now on yes i heard that yeah they're
gonna take the russian idea yeah well
let's do something
the same [ __ ] that said freedom
fries instead of french fries
come on you know uh uh
there was a guy that uh ivan the guy
that lived across uh the alley from me
and he
was pickled man this dude
and his wife was always up his ass he
had a trailer on the side of his house
and i'd go in there and mess around you
know we'd go and watch tv he's a gun
collector and we'd go in there and he
was a cool dude big-ass stomach like
extended from drinking
and um
she would be [ __ ] yelling at him and
the door would be open and he'd go
george don't ever get married man
it's a son of a [ __ ] you hear that [ __ ]
i gotta hear that [ __ ] every day because
that's why i drink look at me i'm all
red he was [ __ ] red i'm just drinking
and we had a uh
a small gate
at the house
and
he came over one time looking for my
grandfather and the gate was locked and
that big [ __ ] jumped over that
gate like a high hurdle
and you were like the [ __ ] i said
whatever he's drinking gives you the
ability to [ __ ] leave small gates
i mean that guy did not look like he
could [ __ ] move at all and he gets
over there and like dwight stone like a
scissor kick
and my grandmother and i looked at each
other like did you see that
jumped over the gate that's awesome
never seen it before never seen anybody
do it after i tried to do it before i
sold my grandmother's house i couldn't i
couldn't do it and that [ __ ] in
one move that's beautiful scissor kicked
that gate and something yeah he might
have been drinking britta vodka he he
was uh yeah he was he was pickled but he
was awesome
sex on the countertop was that the sex
on the countertop was a good drink that
we did we also did
we had so many fun
trailer team yeah we did the trailer
teeny yeah
is it all kind of low level
can you get by with some
we had what would we have the uh
the
shirley temple beth yeah what was the
one with the banana we did the hard on
banana oh god oh that was the um penis
collateral it's the penis colada the
penis collada was very good and they are
actually really good drinks and we're
going to teach everybody how to make
them at the beginning yeah we get
creative yeah i think that's good yeah i
think that's good i don't think people i
don't think people
you know my neighbor over there ralph uh
when i lived in sherman oaks would say
hey joe how about a high ball like in
the afternoon
he had these high ball glasses and he
would come out and i would go back into
the house and ann would be like are you
[ __ ] up i said [ __ ] ralph man give
me a high ball [ __ ] up because you're
like it's time like hypeball time was
like about four o'clock in the afternoon
yeah
and uh and uh
i haven't thought of a high ball forever
what was it between a high ball and a
thing on that mark and a thing that's a
mexican coming on between the other high
ball i mean i mean he had the long i
mean he had to get he had he'd come in
with the trailer and everything in the
tray to get caught in the [ __ ] carpet
uh and the little thing with ice and all
that said the long oh man yeah yeah i
love it so i found it the difference
between so a high ball refers to like
particularly if it's in a tall glass so
like it minimizes the bubbles and keeps
the bubbles in there as opposed to a low
ball which is like a whiskey glass where
you want to get more of like the or the
aroma you know when you get older low
balls
he knows everything i googled it it's
easy
hang in the toilet ball
but nobody nobody does like it like in
like in europe it's tea time like at
four right i mean it's just a and they
take the siesta in spain okay but here
in america when you're working class
nobody ever takes a
a break at florida
in spain they're more they're productive
they look at you he slept for the last
hour yeah
yesterday
right on i'm going to take a nap after
this delicious thing yeah so do you do
you still have that restaurant at san
miguel yeah
yeah you're involved in the food there
no i heard about some friends though but
you yeah yeah we put the menu together
yeah oh my god did they like it yeah it
was pretty good yeah they're like
bragging i'm like yeah i went to his
restaurant
i didn't think that that that stuff like
that oh stuff just happened so that's so
fast you know since like 2015 but you
know there's beer and then there's
there's tequila that's coming out and
the restaurants are doing great and this
is incredible i've never had anything
like i'm not mad at beer or tequila i'm
glad that you guys like that i wonder
why i wonder why
you guys like that and most people i
guess is it sour cheese what does it
taste like
it's dry it's dry to me it's dry i like
i'm a big fan of sour yeah like she
loves sour i love sour candy and sour
champagnes and brute things so it's yeah
it's really good yeah it has a little
rose yeah it's i
want to see what it looks like in a
glass you you know yeah yeah it's it's
like that color yeah dl hugely would
drink uh
is it manhattan does that have like a
banana in there no old-fashioned a
banana oh no old-fashioned has some
fruit in it
we were in detroit and i drank it's all
sugar
i had a spinach salad and two of those
drinks i had to go to the [ __ ]
hospital with pancreatitis yeah that
[ __ ] is like doctors like what
the [ __ ] did you eat man i said i ate a
spinach salad
two old fashions that [ __ ] no
wonder [ __ ] because [ __ ]
they [ __ ] hook them up i mean it's a
little i mean i couldn't i couldn't
[ __ ] stand upright what the [ __ ] is
this i love this because it does not
have the calories on the can
i never want to know what chicanos you
have to look at wait till you're
drinking it's at the bottom yeah
information at the bottom i've still not
seen it but yeah well listen i wish you
guys uh good if i could ever you know
appear i'd bring gil with me oh thank
you thank you i love that i'm gonna have
to appear in the trailer park we of
course love that
hopefully uh more alert because we need
more alerts uh today we mean more alerts
i love that
thanks thanks gil thanks yeah you guys
have been so challenging a lot of fun
thank you for having us thank you good
luck with the [ __ ] thank you
you